welcome ashitosh thanks karthik
it's a pleasure to be here and uh i look
forward to
next one ah share some insights and of
course have a dialogue with the
community who is
who is there on the webinar today so
thank you once again absolutely
absolutely likewise so let's start off
with another
poll probably to just check in terms of
how people are working and so the
question
right now is what is your resolution for
2021
if you have any elaborate comments do
share it
do share it in the comment box in either
the q a or the chat box
you've got about 10 seconds remaining
three two one and done
okay a vast majority but 70
say that they want to learn new skill
very encouraging
very very encouraging great so that sets
the tone for
the webinar today and uh just to start
off probably
we can immediately deep dive into the
question or the title of the webinar
which essentially is what i should watch
what do you think is a role that
learning or upskilling plays in the
redefining work today
so uh i think i'll support
what i'm gonna say with data points
later in the slides but
it's an absolute must it's an absolutely
important thing which everybody should
make it the top of their list or the
resolutions you might gonna make for
this here
focus on learning uh learning is a
continuous uh kind of
endeavor and then upskilling or
re-skilling
uh so that you have the required skills
to be successful
in your career i i have a lot of doctors
in my family
and i see a lot of them continuously
learning
about new developments new medicines new
procedures which are coming out
and i i don't think so any other
profession has that focus on learning as
doctors do
so i think we probably need to learn
from the medical profession and keep
learning so that's my
big thing but i'll give you a lot of
data points today to sub
to you know help understand why it's
important right and it's not like we are
saying it for
or just for anything but there are very
strong data points which have come from
linkedin
economic graph data which is actually
professionals like you and the
professionals on the people
on the webinar they are telling us that
they have to
focus more on learning and you know
really make it part of their career and
professional life
so we'll talk more we'll have uh more
data points who help you through this
but
uh let's get started with few things uh
stuart i don't see slides dvc slides
stuart can you transfer the presentation
i've given you uh presenter privileges
so
please go ahead and share them from your
side uh
okay uh so uh okay let me uh
sorry sorry guys for this uh so it's
okay you present because
it's like slight trouble at the very
last minute so why don't you present and
i'll tell you when to move to the slides
so uh while stuart brings up the
presentation we're gonna focus a lot
we're gonna look back at the year we
just went by
we're gonna talk about the year which is
uh which is we are staring at and what
it means to us and what have we learned
from the last year
and then how we can take some of those
learnings into this year
and be more successful so
2020 uh i mean
you must have heard so many different
ways people must have described 2020
unusual uh you know a lot of different
phrases and i'm not going to use all of
them
i i think it was a disruptive year
disruptive in many many different ways
it disrupted our life
i disrupted the way we used to think
about workplaces
uh so many many different things happen
it disrupted the way we
learned it disrupted the thing the way
we thought about opportunities
so uh i think a lot of a lot has
happened last year we all went first
working from home
which became the norm i'm still working
from home it's been 11 and a half months
and i'm sure a lot of the audience
is still working from home as we went to
work from home
virtual became a center stage and
collaborating virtually became very very
important
a lot of companies who were not very
used to this
uh remote working phenomena uh thought
that
it will not work but uh surprisingly all
of them are finding
that uh you know the workforce is much
more resilient and they figure out
innovative ways
to make it work so virtual collaboration
is at the center stage we are
collaborating virtually
uh by using various technologies so that
we can keep doing with the work we were
doing
economy took a big hit you know you all
know about it and
what it meant for us was uh the
opportunities before us
uh also took a big hit especially in
march and april
and lately globally if all of us went
into pandemic
working from home uh the opportunity
size was reduced
heavily but in all this in all this
which sounds like a little bit of gloom
doom
uh you know what we found was that
people were
leveraging their professional networks a
lot more and it became the single most
liver for professionals to connect with
the people
and that was very clearly seen in our
data
you know we saw a lot more engagement on
linkedin a lot of people were leveraging
linkedin
uh of course job seeking was the number
one thing
but they were also using messaging to
connect with the people they were also
using collaboration
and virtual selling uh to connect with
people
so uh i think uh that 2020 was really
disruptive
and uh transformational here but i think
if you look back all the major changes
which happened in like little last
hundred years all of them were driven by
a major disruption an event
which uh which really shook up things
and then what
off what came after that was you know
something new something which helped
become us more efficient and became
really better at what we do so maybe
this is the disruption we needed and we
will see what
what what the future looks like right so
uh if we go and go to the next slide uh
stuart
uh one thing which came out
very clearly is that amongst those
challenging times
uh one thing that stood out was a
dramatic
boost in india's appetite for learning
and upskilling to stay out of the curve
so we saw uh you know a lot of
uh demand a lot of interest in
upskilling and re-skilling
now let's understand this words right
upskilling
is uh you know learning new skills
within the same job function
so you know i'm a software developer i
learn a new language
i learn new coding skills uh you know
that's upskilling reskilling is learning
absolutely new skill for a different job
function
so let's say i was in an industry x and
then i go and do something
totally different than in industry and
that's reskilling
so upskilling and reskilling are very
very uh
important uh and as i was saying earlier
like we all of us felt that we went to
all these good colleges and after that
we do no need to learn
that is not going to be the case anymore
we have to continuously upskill and
reskill
so that we stay relevant and we stay uh
connected to the skills which are
required for the new set of jobs which
are coming our way
so uh upskilling with killing we're
gonna focus a lot on this you're gonna
hear a lot about this
but uh you know in uh last 11 months
what we have realized
and uh you know that online learning
is really a boon it's really a gift to
us online learning has been there for
many many years
right it was always there we used to do
some bit of it but suddenly it's become
much more uh it's become much more
mainstream it's become much more part of
our life
and april march april when we went into
those lockdowns
uh you know uh there was uh you know
increased learning which is happening on
linkedin
uh you know the linkedin learning hours
were just climbing through the
roof and people were using the time when
they were home and very start of the
early lockdowns people were saying let's
learn new skills let's learn
uh you know something relevant to our
jobs
so uh that's what you see it's some of
the stats that
three and the five professionals have
increased their time spent in online
learning going forward so there we asked
a question we thought that was a
just a bubble in all this is happening
but
you know people when we asked a question
in october in december
you know they they said that 57
professionals said they will increase
their time spent
on learning uh going forward uh
twenty percent uh there's an increase of
twenty percent
uh in the demand for indian
professionals with digital skills
and you know just hold to this data
point i'll explain to you how we got to
that and it's a
very very important one and i i'm sure
all of you are experiencing wherever
you are joining us today from uh which
whichever part of the world increasingly
use of digital
in any any industry and you must be
seeing it and
you know uh right from uh you know
retail
uh because we we don't want to go to a
store and so the retail supplement
supply chains are becoming more digital
uh you know
uh i don't want to go to a mall so i'm
going to boyce buy stuff online and that
supply chain is getting more digital
right so there are many many examples of
this
digitization which is happening right
now in fact i got so many calls from
traditional industries
packaging manufacturing people who
wanted to know more how to further
digitize their operations
uh so that you know they can stay
relevant in this current time so
digital skills is going to be very very
important and there's a
it's going to be a lot more demand uh on
digital
skills 85 percent recruiters in india
believe that re-skilling the workforce
is very important impactful and
it's going to reshape the future of
recruiting
this and it's not like you know they're
they are coming they're drawing this
data point from anywhere
they're looking at what the demand is
and that they're seeing that
you know if it is more digital if people
don't have those skills they will have
to reskill and they will get
you will see increasingly use of uh
the levers like assessments uh like even
if before you can apply for a job
you will have to qualify or you will
have to
uh maybe do a small test online uh so
that you can apply for that job
right so i think they will be increasing
focus on the skills before you can apply
and even in during the interview process
uh it's no longer like past experience
is going to be helpful but it's really
going to be about
uh you know whether you have the right
skills for the job
and the next data point on the slide is
even more important
that there are there's a lot of distance
out there today in the system like
a lot of people have lost jobs lots of
industries uh
there is no path uh for them to come
back they will
they will see a much slower recovery so
all the individuals or professionals in
those
industries uh who don't have a job
currently are ready to pivot their
carriers
and pivot means you're gonna do
something very different from what you
have been doing
and uh maybe you don't have those skills
and you're gonna acquire those skills
and then you know do something really
really different
i think all of us have pivoted uh in our
careers in the past
i have pivoted i was not even connected
to digital when i came back to india in
2010
and i was doing something very very
different i was in sales in id services
but i i thought that digital is going to
be the future and that's where i pivoted
and i learned the new skills and
acquired the new skills of course i did
it
on my pace in my own comfort zone right
now the times are slightly different uh
you know you
you're gonna be uncomfortable but the
idea here is that if you don't
if you come from an industry which
doesn't have a quick recovery
pivot your skills uh re-skill yourself
so that you can get a job
so these are important data points and
how do we get these data points is again
uh economic graph data as well as we
have been conducting workforce
uh confidence index service on the
platform
so that we get the pulse of the
workforce professional workforce
and understand what they are thinking
right so these are the data points we
are seeing
uh over the last eight nine ten months
which are very very relevant
so uh you know what uh it's gonna happen
is when we looked at the economic graph
data
uh you know what we saw that there will
be 150 new jobs
150 million new jobs will be created uh
by 2025 that will require digital skills
now there are a couple of things here so
150 million new jobs you might say
are these net new jobs are these uh jobs
which don't exist today no
these are not net new jobs these are
current jobs which will get
uh you know reclassified under digital
umbrella so
digital skills will become very very
important and these are not net new jobs
so
uh you know it's very important that the
people
who are applying should acquire those
digital skills before you qualify for
those jobs
so professionals must prepare themselves
for a digital ready world it's
very very important right so uh i think
we
we have uh and i'll tell you about this
in couple of slides that we have
uh as part of the microsoft uh ecosystem
we have come up with initiative which
can help you acquire those digital
skills
so uh you know i know as well as the
roles which uh which will
uh which will be coming up so
let's let's take another quick look at
another post so see
what skill sets you are aiming to
acquire in 2021
i would love to really know the audience
and what they are thinking about
uh so let's i'll just take few seconds
pause so that you guys can quickly fill
up the poll and then we will see the
results
okay maybe few more seconds and then
let's
close the ball
okay
let's uh i see the a and b
as the most important one sorry they're
getting cut off on my screen so i don't
know what those options
are uh programming and coding 42
very good business analysis 52
that's very good as well and
communication and creativity
collaboration network okay okay so i you
know i think the
couple of those are very good and by the
way a lot of people a lot of you have
picked up
uh communication and creativity so i
think along with hard skills soft skills
are still going to be very very
important right
so program programming and coding and
business analysis and you will see i'll
show you some data points at the end
that
i think this audience is thinking well
about that
require the future of the skills as well
as the future of the jobs
so we should get digital ready digital
transformation is going to catalyze an
upskilling and reskilling revolution we
need it
we need it right if there are 150
million jobs which are going to be open
over the next five three four years
which are going to be digital in nature
and flavor
it's very very important that that
transformation happens on upskilling and
reskilling so uh you know uh there is uh
uh how how do you get there and that's
exactly the slide talks about so
uh you know linkedin is part of the
microsoft ecosystem
and uh github is another company which
has been acquired by
microsoft so last june uh we came up
with this uh
skilling initiative along with microsoft
and github
where we launched this global skills
initiative
with the aim to bring digital skills to
around 25 million people
worldwide so we have made 10 learning
paths
uh free as part of this
where you can just log into that website
and you know
get those acquired skills through those
learning paths and learning path are
basically a curated stream of content or
learning uh
videos or learning uh curriculum which
you have to take in a sequence so that
you can acquire those skills
uh github has also joined which is uh
you know
devops uh skills which you can learn
through github and microsoft learning as
well
so i think we uh as i said earlier there
were there are hard skills which you can
acquire and there
are good soft skills which you can
acquire as well because uh
both are required uh to be uh you know
ready
for this uh next set of jobs which are
gonna get available
uh i i'm happy to report that as part of
this uh
india india had 1.1 million engaged
learners on this initiative so that's
roughly 7.74 lakh learners which have
been
engaged on this on this initiative
and then we partnered with national
skill development corporation as well as
cc
uh so that we have provided free
learning uh parts uh
on their website as well so that there
is a more availability for the people
who are looking to acquire those skills
and which are in demand in the economy
you're mute
sorry about mute i couldn't hear you so
yeah so i was just saying to uh
we just wanted to kind of discuss in
terms of what are the top jobs in
today's economy because
uh the kind of trends that you're seeing
in 2020 have been unprecedented
whether it be because of the current
pandemic or because of digitization
or because of uh e-learning or online
learning really driving
um upskilling and re-skilling so what
are the kind of
areas or categories or departments that
will really benefit from all this
and what are the kind of roles that you
see are going to
really come up in 2021 and why
so uh i think the slide says it all
uh to your question these are the top
jobs uh
10 top jobs which are in demand in
today's economy
and as i was saying when we did the
skilling question with this group
over this community uh software
developer
uh was part of that the coding skills
right so software developer
is definitely a job which is gonna be
hot and it's gonna be in demand sales
representative
project manager id administrator one
thing which you will which is not
pretty pretty clear on this slide is
apart from few
which reference to the digital part but
all of
all of these jobs will have a digital
flavor so sales rep
if i if you're a sales rep today without
literally
all uh economies in the world
working remotely how do you sell
remotely
right and that's gonna become like how
do you sell remotely you're gonna use
some of those digital
technologies to sell at linkedin we have
sales navigator
which we talk about which you can use to
do your
professional networking to build your
sales pipeline to connect virtually
with the decision makers so you are a
sales person but you are using those
digital
skills and technologies uh to sell uh
so it's true for all of them uh customer
service specialist project manager
uh some of these jobs are already
leveraging a lot of digital skills
but you know now in the future that's
going to become
extremely extremely important so digital
market here is another job which is
going to be very very hard
data analysts financial analysts like
financial analysts
i think i don't think so there's a
financial analyst in the world we still
does it on the pen and paper
everybody use microsoft excel and
there's gonna be further
use of more technologies to get there so
uh
to your question these are the top 10
jobs all with a
very common theme of being digital so
digital is going to be a central part of
all these jobs and as i said earlier
when manufacturing companies packaging
companies reached out
uh you know they were all talking about
digitizing their
supply chains i mean there was a
manufacturing company who was thinking
about how they can digitize their
production line
so that uh you know they they can they
get they're ready for the new world so
they were looking for
even let's say people who are gonna
operate the plants but it's going to be
all digital
so i think this rule is going to be a
core skill
and it's going to manifest in all jobs
literally over the next few years
so that's the top 10 jobs but let's look
at
let's go to the next slide and there's a
little you're gonna get a little more
color
uh to your question as well so uh
you know as i was saying technology
center stage of
all the skilling which we need and uh
you know
uh what we have seen from a data
perspective is that
uh that of course our learning was on
linkedin learning is
three x from april to december so people
are learning more people are
getting on linkedin learning and really
really trying to understand uh and pivot
their careers into the right directions
the top five courses on linkedin were
project management professionals pmp
online marketing for the fundamentals
time management
so it's a mix of both hard and soft
skills
uh most in demand jobs in india are
software engineers business development
manager sales and
sales manager business analyst again all
with the flavor of the
digital at the backbone of all those
skills
all the other jobs and the fastest
growing skills in india and you can see
python the programming language machine
learning data structures
digital marketing uh not surprising
right like you know
i think as everybody is remote and
everybody is
uh they are looking uh to you know
really figure out how to market to all
of the consumers all reach out to all
the decision makers
and digital marketing is at the flavor
an html5
so i think uh what if you if you ask me
what are you trying to say here like the
most important thing is
learning learning making learning part
of your
daily life uh you know if you are a
fresher
if you are a mid-career executive or
even a senior executive
learning has to be continuously part of
your
of your day and your planning we at
linkedin we have very well established
routines where all of us learn i also
spend time and company gives
us time that we can invest
all that in learning new skills and i
think as
as organizations as companies also will
have a greater responsibility
to make sure that our employees though
they are virtual
they are still developing their skills
and they they are learning so
i think they we have the responsibility
and that they also came out in the
survey that
employees are worried that if they are
virtual how will they develop how will
they develop and acquire new skills and
the answer is
online learning and skilling so uh so as
i said these are the flavors uh which
we are coming out very strongly now
as an individual as a as an individual
professional
those are the things you need to worry
about but what's happening from a
company perspective an organization
perspective is also important to
understand so
uh old paradigms will die and that's
very very important
they will not die suddenly there will be
a gradual decline and there'll be
gradual rethink of of some of those
paradigms
so for example there were companies who
never could imagine
the employees being virtual right now
they will have to rethink
uh they were companies who are very nine
to five
uh thinkers that employees come in at
night and they
leave office at five when you're virtual
there is
there's not such thinking right you know
i have a whole day and i can structure
my day according to my needs
the most important thing is my
deliverables and as long as i'm sticking
to my drill
deliverables i i want to have some
flexibility in my
day so all of this will be rethought
all of these paradigms will be rethought
and then
there will be a balancing of the new and
the old
and there'll be a flexibility which will
be definitely part of
all of those things which are needed uh
what
so how do we help companies in such
place i think one thing which we have
done is uh virtual events
uh you know which is also very very uh
cool product which we are building which
is uh which is available today
so what in b2b industry uh and even in
b2c events are a big part of
uh all your marketing and outreach to
consumers
uh and uh you know events uh in pandemic
are very difficult right you have to
worry about many many different
dimensions
i don't think so there are many events
happening right now and we are not in
that place
so but the business has to go on so how
do
we support that we have created virtual
events on linkedin where you can create
a small community uh on linkedin
invite them to events using linkedin
data uh
host the event on linkedin where you can
use linkedin live
uh so that you can broadcast that and
then uh you know
once the event is done you can follow up
with them post the events uh you can
still communicate to that community
through linkedin events so i think
the key point here is that some of this
reimagination
of some of the way work happened in
companies is gonna happen
right so a linkedin events is an example
uh we have a lot of
takeover take up of this linkedin events
uh
top indian companies have used linkedin
events in the last few months and
they are finding success with it uh
other thing is remote jobs as i was
saying
earlier about it right i was in general
browsing few companies job sites
and i saw that you know this one company
which i'll not name
but uh there was very clearly the
locations
uh bangalore singapore all global
locations and they had another tab there
we said remote
so it's okay you can be anywhere you can
work remotely and
there were certain jobs which are marked
as remote so the remote
is gonna like the flexibility is gonna
come into some of the job scenario
and uh we have seen that you know there
are
uh you know more remote job postings
from march to may
last year and top level five remote job
titles that witness truth you know you
can be there customer rep
representatives
internet analyst key account manager
freelance writer
so i i don't think so all jobs are meant
to be remote there will be some jobs
which will require you to be in the
office or some jobs
eventually will require you to meet
clients and more collaboration
in person but there are certain jobs
which are absolutely fine for you to be
remote and
keep working uh on keep doing the work
you are doing and the last bit is
virtual recruiting that reimagination
has
happened a lot already right so
virtual recruiting a lot of recruitment
is happening right now virtually
and you know virtual internet interviews
are becoming a new normal and new
standard in a way
and i think people are also realizing
the efficiency of
uh some bit of children doing right you
know i think it's becoming much more
easier to coordinate the skills
uh sorry coordinate the calendars it's
becoming a lot more easier for
candidates uh to you know not travel
uh to some other offices and just get on
a vc or get on a
uh zoom call or a webex or whatever
microsoft teams which
whichever technology you're using and uh
connect
to the interviewers there are seven
skills which are required when you
interview virtually and that
that also is available on linkedin
learning so
you know you have to be uh you have to
make yourself
in your interview skills slightly more
sharper in within 20 30 minutes
you have to connect with the person on
the screen and make sure that you make
uh make a very very clear representation
of your skill sets
and what you bring to the table right so
all of this needs to be
imagined so there's a lot of imagination
happening uh
uh from company size as well in events
and jobs
and uh and virtual recruiting now
i think i've used a lot of data points
i've shown uh
how those data points are manifesting
themselves i want to give you a couple
of real life examples of what we saw
uh in terms of case study so if you can
go to the next slide i want to talk
about
a company which all of us in india are
very famous uh very very aware about
is atel which is a largely complaint in
india
and uh this company as uh like all of us
went into the lockdown and uh you know
they they were
very very clear about
employees learning and development and
uh
they they they use linkedin learning and
they have recorded
historical high in terms of uh linkedin
learning hours
so uh you know so 2x the number of
learners logging in
35 increase in monthly repeat learners
all of the statistics
show the uptick uh from the employees on
linkedin learning
and uh you know they they are seeing
increased
engagement from their employees on on
linkedin learning so 52
monthly repeat learners and the quote
which you can see on the screen
is very very uh reflective like where
they are saying it's very very important
for them to help the employees to help
build their resilience and help keep on
developing
so you will see many many such examples
around you
where we are i'm just quoting one of
them but uh you know it
leveraging linkedin learning to ensure
that the employees keep learning from
wherever they are and whatever the
situation they are
another example is away from linkedin
which is of a company
uh which i am sure all of you heard uh
shopify
uh and how shopify help business go
online
uh they created those digital
storefronts
uh when the the world went into lockdown
and suddenly everybody wanted to shop
and
buy things online so they created this
digital
store fronts where they onboarded many
many merchants
uh uh and like 120 percent jump in the
net new merchants in over six months
and uh the company was able to help
several businesses
uh help the kobet 19 storm and
uh you know generate greater revenues
for them in the pandemic and for them as
well
so shopify is a great example of a
company innovating
and helping others as well and during
this time so that they can
keep their businesses running and uh you
know they really benefit from them
so uh so i think these are a couple of
examples
uh the most important thing uh is that
we'll
as as an individual we will have to
rethink
about our careers and professionals
we'll have to rethink some of our skills
and we'll have to rethink how we space
out our day and in part in terms of what
we need to do
as well as learning organizations will
have to innovate as well
on uh on thinking about how they're
gonna
market how they're gonna uh you know
think about uh
offices and the flexibility they need to
provide
some of the jobs gonna go remote and of
course some of the
processes like interviewing will become
more virtual
one of the things which is happening and
that's where we saw a lot of traction on
linkedin is the feeling of community
feeling of being in together
is becoming very very strong so
professionals
are leveraging their communities they're
leveraging their networks
uh in this tough times to connect and to
understand better uh
you know and you know share more so
messaging on linkedin i'm sure all of
you have uh
used messaging on linkedin that's it the
record highs because people have used
messaging very effectively
to either network uh to
help people to get help from the america
network
so i think uh it's very very important
that we
take this moment to really reflect
and decide what's important for us as
well as
you know put some of this learning into
center of everything we do
so uh so that's what i thought i'll
share with you guys today there were
some data points there were some good
examples
and there were some look into the future
what top jobs and what top skills are
going to be important in the days to
come
i would highly recommend and in you know
you know say that you guys should all
think about
uh building digital skills if you don't
have already and if you have digital
skills
you can see how you can fortify them for
the uh enough skill there
so it was uh great having uh
this discussion today and from a slight
perspective that's all i wanted to
share and that's what i wanted to
present let's see
if uh there are any question and there's
one more poll on the screen
uh you know you would learn a few more
things about linkedin but
i just wanted to check with the audience
who are on the on the webinar
what would you like to hear more from us
so that uh you know we know
and then we can uh figure out like ways
to communicate backwards to you
with that uh karthik let's see if we
have some questions
yes thank you for a wonderful session uh
let's i think we've got quite a few
questions let me pick out one to start
with probably
uh so there's an interesting question
which kind of addresses
uh the efficacy of e-learning or online
learning
vis-a-vis regular campus courses and the
questioning as to
is is the approach towards or the
affinity towards e-learning courses as a
credible
certification or a credible example for
performance or
expertise is that changing in terms of
today's recruitment
it is it is slowly changing for sure uh
so i think uh you know there are two
parts to this first of all what you
learn
in person uh and what you learn when
you're in a classroom
has its own value and then there are
things which you can supplement that
learning through e-learning
as well as there are certain things
which you can definitely
purely learn uh online so i don't think
so
it's a question of choosing one over the
other like how can you leverage
both the models to ensure that you
acquire the right skills and keep
learning
for working professionals who are people
who are on the jobs
right you know online learning is a
great supplement
right i can do my whole day of work and
then when i have those moments when i
have that half an hour
uh you know i can quickly plug in and
learn foreign i'll give you my example
i my physical well-being
mantra is to walk a lot
and when i walk i plug into linkedin
learning and
you know listen to those courses right
so
and that way i'm learning something i'm
taking care of my health and i'm
learning so that's one example of how
some of these things are can be fruitful
and can be done
in in as part of your daily schedule
right so i don't think so i want to pick
one over the other
you can use both of them together and
one is
kind of supplementing and complementing
the other one
especially also in interviews probably
these do
have a lot of value in terms of helping
the candidate answer the questions more
clearly
and impressing the interviewer much
better i guess
yeah yeah another question
is in terms of is there a age limit for
upskilling
so uh they're asking whether uh as we
grow ahead in
our career probably for example if a
person is a senior i.t professional with
25 years of experience
can i still upskill can i still reskin
what is your thoughts on that
i i don't think so age is a factor here
or age should be a bar
for us uh you know thinking about
upskilling and rescaling
i'm thinking about acquiring new skills
i want to
you know go and acquire uh new skills on
a few things so i don't like you know
i don't think so that's a reason you
have to be
very mindful of how you want to think
about research for example 25 years
id professional right do you want to
climb up vertically
do you want to go to another industry or
do you want to acquire a net new skill
right so i think you have to make those
conscious choices
uh but i don't think so age is about
there
as well as you know i think uh
you know for the younger people uh you
know
a common thing that you said is you can
learn much faster which i don't
agree but like i think you have a better
spectrum
where you can pick from whereas when you
have become more senior i think that
some of those things get slightly
uh you know constrained but i don't
think so age is a bar here right like it
totally depends on what you want to do
and there's enough examples i'm sure
your networks have examples where people
have said
i'm done with this let me try something
absolutely new and it works right so
uh i don't think so you should put age
as a factor in any of these
conversations
absolutely in fact uh traditionally we
wear kind of the mindset that you study
and then you start working
now it's kind of cyclical where you
study while working and you work while
studying
so that's the kind of way it's changing
yeah absolutely
completely uh also so now it's spoken
about the younger professionals and the
older professionals so
for example a younger professional if he
or she gets into the
industry started working for a year what
are the things that they they should
keep their eyes open
for uh in order to understand what are
the right things to upskill in
so i think i got distracted a little bit
so can you repeat the question again
uh so i'm saying uh so early early
professionals probably a year into the
job what are the things that they need
to be
looking out for and kind of be
interested in so that they can say okay
these are the areas that i need to
upskill in
yeah i think there are many dimensions
here so first of all
uh uh career ali ali states uh early
career
professionals digital first look at like
your own digital
skills capability i would say and you
know
kind of do a little bit of audit on that
your required field
and what are the digital skills you have
if you don't have acquire the digital
skills
number two most important soft skills
you know
before the pandemic and i'm saying
before the pandemic there were many many
jobs and i forgot the number
we had a metric there which so many jobs
were left
which were never you know filled because
of
lack of soft skills i had the hard
skills but i didn't have the soft skills
right so again
i would say all stage career
professionals should look at the soft
skills required
uh you know now we are learning
virtually like for example time
management and it was one of the top
learning courses up there how to manage
my time when i'm working virtually or
remotely
it's going to be very important skill
you can have all the hard skills but if
you can't manage your time
you're not going to be very successful
and the company is going on a very happy
with
your deliverables right so i think uh
you know
look at the hard skills and especially
from a digital lens
and then the bunch of soft skills
collaboration is such an important skill
i think when we were working in offices
of course collaboration was more
important
but it's gone to a tricky angle now
because we're all working virtually
so how do you collaborate how do you
reach out to the right people how do you
ask for help or give help so some of the
soft skills are gonna become very very
very
important as we go along perfect
couldn't have removed
uh right i think that's all we have time
for right now i think we've
answered a few very interesting
questions uh thank you so much for your
time
and this wonderful webinar i'm pretty
sure that the audience enjoyed it as
much as i did
yeah so handing it over to stewart once
yeah thank you thank you
thank you again and uh also kartik um
and of course you can connect with
ashitosh over
linkedin here is his url
and um we
will also like to tell you about
a new program from simple learn called
skill
up uh similar to the microsoft learning
and linkedin learning initiative that
ashutosh described
we offer free access to a thousand
hours of video content and over 300
in-demand skills
so we view that as a complementary to
what linkedin
and microsoft are doing and
we invite you to check that out
um please connect with us
on our social channels on facebook
twitter and linkedin
and we will be sending out a link to you
of the recording of this
webinar uh we'll include with that
urls for the microsoft
slash linkedin learning initiative
and we'll also include an invitation to
the next simply learn
webinar which we hope you will all join
us for
and that concludes our webinar today
so thank you all very much
and when you log off you should see a
survey please take a couple moments to
answer those questions
and the webinar has concluded thank you
you